我可以做的
字幕提供
大家晚安大家晚安
有聽到聲音嗎
等一下啊
等一下
好
字幕組成員 字幕組成員 字幕組成員
有聽到聲音嗎?有聽到?這樣子應該比較大聲
這樣子這樣
有聽到聲音嗎?有這樣子有嗎?
有聲音,有聲音,沒聲音
應該是有聲音
沒聲音
有聲音
剛剛調到耳機了,所以沒聲音
有聲音喔
我剛剛有看到,哇聖呼說
這個月拿10萬賺15萬喔
厲害厲害
拿10萬賺15萬,那應該是有開槓桿喔
他說感謝小哥交處置股
這個月用10萬做處置回收15萬
來來來
這旁邊的聊天室訊息啊
我這個聊天室訊息我沒有辦法
沒辦法直接播
給各位看一下
這裡
喔這邊
哇這個月用10萬做處置回收15萬欸
蠻強的
其實處置
處置真的是
那個波動很大
很大啊呵呵呵小姐好很像三毛爸不敢留言呵呵呵欸 真的還他們留言之前還會看一下餒
嗆個兩句就不留了
呵呵呵
燒江仙處之
呃這個賺很多的叫我不要講
呃一定的啦
嗯賺很多都會
這很多賺很多都
都會希望我不要講啦
那一定的
不要再講了
這麼好賺的東西不要再講了
那其實這跟行情有關
因為最近的行情真的是
處置太好做了
所以一定要趁最近這麼好做的時候
跟各位講
那我們也不是叫你去做空
也沒有處置我們
不大鼓勵做空行為
我們處置都是
比較偏多的
處置都比較偏多
哇 真的 少講一點 哇 一點叫不要講
每次下處置我還會疊更低
那有點慘
好啦 那我們今天就來講處置啦
我們今天要講處置神器全攻略
好 差點忘了
連一下我的desk in
各位啊 這軟體蠻好的啦
本集沒有業配 好不好
本集desk in沒業配
希望desk in跟我業配一下
因為我真心覺得它好用
免密連線
同意
我也自曉
然後呢它就可以來
讓各位看一下我的手機
它這個很方便
手機我拿著
拿著就可以來
我拿在我手上就可以把我手機上面的
畫面這個投影出去
很方便
來這邊
好這就是我手機的畫面
各位看我的處置神器放這裡 當中的神手放這裡
處置神器
唉 今天走了4800步
走的有點少
好吧 各位啊 打開處置神器呢
打開處置神器 我們先給各位看
打開處置神器呢
一進來 它有個監測跟公告
那今天公告 今天有一檔終於被關了
叫全新
全新今天被關了啦 而且是
比較嚴重的20分鐘
20分鐘
前進監被20分鐘關了
所以他未來的走勢
可能比較弱一點
可能啦
這沒有一定啦好然後呢我們的監測監測監也比較特別一點點監測監比較特別這個給各位看一下監測呢
這個
比較特別的是
那個第一檔
我們來看一下
這個有一檔叫做聯發科
聯發科出來了
來 各位看一下聯發科
聯發科他有條件喔
條件是3150
大語等於會被關
所以呢明天呢聯發科呢他講
我是覺得聯發科影響
我就覺得五分鐘影響不會太大
為什麼 因為
聯發科五分鐘讓你
那個沒筆不能超過九張
嘿 聯發科沒筆不能超過九張
開什麼玩笑
誰有能力沒筆超過十張啊
呵呵呵
喔
你有能力沒筆超過十張嗎
一般人沒有能力沒筆超過十張嘛
所以我覺得聯發科的五分鐘
其實影響不會太大
應該說他有可能會回頭
但是我覺得聯發科他這個處置
對一般人而言
對一般常人而言
聯發科 本來被人都買零股了
對不對
好不容易欠長一張
大概只能買一張
對不對
以前一千多塊
還好現在三千多塊
三千多塊買一張就
這個
就很了不起
那你要 沒筆要超過9張
這個我是覺得
我是覺得有點困難
好
來來來來看一下
欸這個 我們來看一下 這邊這邊
這個我把它把它理開
有沒有看到
3月21號開始投入處置車位到目前為止全勝
就是我們那個
開始講處置的時候
全勝
三网真的誇張 昨天買今天掌鈴
三网我有買 我有買
我今天沒有賣 三网還沒賣啊
今天掌鈴幹嘛賣
哦 處置神器今天不要優惠
不要優惠
臭名喔 不要優惠
好 連發人扯啊
哦 好
那怎麼看明天經濟出外
那我們來給哥哥看一個東西
怎麼看喔 我們要給
我們先來看一下處置神器
他這個東西 我覺得這邊還不錯
啊這邊啊這邊呢有個處置統計
那處置統計呢他有分5分跟20分
5分跟20分所以呢各位你可以研究一下5分跟20分的這個統計的數字那5分的5分的平均漲跌幅大概在儲置的當天
會稍微跌一點
但也跌不多
平均來說啦
平均來說
那這儲置後一天
這儲置後兩天
就是儲置後呢
通常稍微弱一點
但後面蠻強的
但出關那一天呢會比較弱一點
為什麼
這個是主要原因是
因為5分鐘大家都可以買啦
跟各位講5分鐘大家都可以買
聯話客5分鐘你也可以買啦
你就不要說啊聯話客我一直買10張
我沒辦法買喔 那種人很少
聯話客我沒辦法敲499
那種人更少啦對不對
聯話客沒辦法敲499
對啦
處置之後你就不能敲499了啦
喔 你說你一個戶頭喔
你一個戶頭呢 只能敲那個
那個每筆只能敲9張
然後一天只能敲29張
一天只能敲29張
但你可以分好幾個戶頭啦
所以聯發科我是覺得影響不大
這5分鐘
那但是20分鐘喔 20分鐘就不一樣喔
來我們來看一下20分鐘
那處置呢假如遇到20分鐘喔
他在當天跌的會比較多
但未來大部分都漲
就連出貫那天也漲
為什麼出貫那天容易漲呢 因為
舉例來講喔 像經濟 經濟明天出貫嘛
但是經濟這20分鐘的時候呢 一堆人不能買
經濟呢最近是20分鐘處置
一堆人是不能買進的喔
因為經濟你要買你要做什麼事啊
這個處置是20分鐘
我們來看一下 處置有分5分鐘跟20分鐘
這是20分鐘
那經濟有個那個試戳哥每天在亂戳
真的很煩
盤中一直戳漲你們戳諜品
一直戳一直戳
他們都不會停電
他家都不會停電嗎 一直給人家戳
今天這環欸 每天都戳
戳到大家都
都不曉得那個經濟的
這個經濟的真實的價格在那邊
都不曉得經濟的真實價格
那這經濟其實今天的波動很小
因為大家都靜待他出關
那平均來講啦
平均來講 我們再回來
平均來講20分鐘的儲置
在出關後其實
平均的漲幅還是蠻高的
也就是說這種儲置股呢
其實很大部分都是強勢股
那強勢股呢它還是會有它應有的
應有的慣性啦
就還是
還是會漲啦
所以處置呢假如有機會回檔的話
那都是
是老天爺送禮物給各位吃的
所以組織谷呢 我們就很喜歡
很喜歡做什麼
很喜歡做 讓子回頭
好 那什麼是讓子回頭呢
我們帶來介紹一下
一開始請各位加一下這QR Code
QR Code加一下這個密碼
8個8
密碼8個8 各位先加一下
密碼8個8 那這個都會有
都會有詐騙混進來喔 各位記得喔
凡是在社群裡面 邀請你加另外一個群的都詐騙
那有可能大頭皆是我
名字也是我 但是他只要一出現我們就把他踢掉
他一出現我們就把他踢掉
那我們這群比較特別是我們踢掉的時候你看不出來
我們把他踢掉的畫面
小運輸把這畫面給關掉了
就是他被踢掉你可能不知道
不過他的訊息我們會把它刪掉
訊息會把它刪掉
而且密碼是8個8
那只要詐騙混進來
我們可能過幾天又會換密碼
不然詐騙這很煩啊
每天看詐騙很煩
詐騙每天在我那邊留言三寶爸
喔這很煩
每次一發文
就要追蹤三寶爸
三寶爸有各式各樣的發文欸
我覺得是怎樣
各式各樣的粉專啊
那種粉專都騙人了啦
再跟各位講
那種粉專都騙人了,來我們來看一下
我們來看一下三寶爸
欸三寶爸
剛剛有的被我刪掉了
就是我們一發文,啊底下就有什麼
底下就留言了,留言三寶爸
這反
反正底下留言有那個
有那個,唉呦
很多我們都已經刪掉了
底下留言
我看所有留言,欸
看不到
嗯...因為最近一直嗆他就比較少出現
欸這裡 欸這裡沒嗆
這邊應該也 欸這邊也消失了
可能被系統隱藏住了
喔 怎麼說這個
底下留言三寶爸的一輩子困在櫃裏
這麼 這麼毒的事
這麼毒的住 我害底下今天真的
很少留三寶爸
欸這個這個不是啊
這個是正常的 我們來看一下不正常的不正常的三寶爸三寶爸到處的人這邊也看不到之前真的很多啦那有的都被系統的都被關掉
你看這邊有四個留言
只剩一個留言正常
三個留言都是三寶爸
那個留言真的很煩
好
處置神器APP的名稱是什麼
大家的問題真的很好玩
處置神器APP的名稱當然是處置神器啊
但是處置神器
小哥請問一下為什麼圓金今天開地突然左高
開地就是有人在賣嘛 左高就是有人在買嘛
好不好 就這樣子 好不好 就這樣
各位不要想太多 好啦
我們再回來 只要看到一些
這個好玩的齁
好玩的 我們再把留言給各位看
好啦 那我們再回來齁 再回來
那這個儲治神器呢 其實它最
最重要的功能 叫做 浪子回頭
就是呢 我們有寫一個訊號
叫 浪子回頭 浪子回頭什麼意思
就是它 它是強勢谷的儲治啊
強勢谷 弱勢谷我們不看喔 跟各位講
儲治有分強勢跟弱勢喔
如果弱勢盡儲治的 你不用理它
我們理的是強勢盡儲治的
那強勢被關的
那強勢被關的呢 這種呢
其實拉回就找買點
拉回找買點
那時候我就寫一句話
浪子回頭你不賠東山再起你是誰
那浪子回頭呢我都賠了
浪子回頭我用力賠好不好
浪子回頭我賠的可用力了好不好
來來來來
全市場浪子回頭我賠的最用力
來來給各位看一下
這個這個這個
這裡
這夠用力了吧
喔經濟浪子回頭
來經濟呢它是儲置喔跌28在4月27號
這個是比浪子回頭更浪子回頭
的訊號叫處置後跌20%
那以前這個處置後跌20%我們有寫個名詞啊
後來我覺得名詞不要太多了 太多大家會搞混
那我就直接寫什麼
處置後跌20%
那處置後跌20%我拼命買跟各位講
處置後跌20%是老天爺掉的禮物啊
經濟我們之前就講了
經濟這個一定得買好不好
處置後跌20%你還不買
喔 處之後跌20%你還不買
松山哥演講會進去聽嗎
欸沒票沒有票可以聽喔 有票有空我一定去訂沒有票好啦這個經濟處置後
跌20%
喔
經濟處置後跌20%
這個
這當然很好啊
那第二個呢
還語
然後訊心
喔 還語訊心
那各位看一下
喔 經濟
這個370張
各位你看一下 我買了這個位置
373 這是4月27號訊號
這邊很多訊號都4月27號
4月27號 那我們來看一下
4月27號那時候發生什麼事啊
4月27號的經濟在這裡
4月27號訊息在這邊
儲之後跌20% 從172塊
儲置完喔 你看從這裡儲置啊
這邊儲置是這個20分鐘儲置嘛
儲置完之後開殺
除之後跌20%
在這一天出現訊號 4月27號
那我在這一天選擇大買
那我的均價 均價呢在這邊
均價就在這裡啊
這個給各位看啊 均價 136.7
136.78
浪子回頭只看漲跌5嗎 沒其他濾網嗎 大概有啊
我們有濾網
我們有
有濾網好不好 我們有濾網 沒有那麼簡單
好不好
我們有濾網
那我們是我們的濾網
我們濾網還沒有濾籌嘛
那籌碼大家可以看一下
這個
為什麼要多加一層呢
這個是本來就這樣
就是
我告訴你現象嘛
然後呢你自己再去看一下籌碼
看你要不要買
你自己再過濾一層
欸
那要不要買你自己要決定好喔
過濾一層要不要買齁
來
再跟各位講一次
這個
這個喔再過濾層
要不要買
看這個就可以了好不好
看這個就可以了
看這裡
看阻力這條線
再跟各位講
這是回檔阻力這條線沒有往下掉
然後你去看他的阻
阻五阻十齁
都會是什麼
都會是正的喔
再跟各位講
你在這邊呢
看到他的阻五阻十呢
都會是正的
阻五阻十都正的
來來來我看一下
這邊 主主持都勝的 來來 我把這邊給貴這裡你看喔 你看經濟到目前為止他的主主還是正的
非常的漂亮
那在前幾天這主主更漂亮
應該都到十級
主主時候
那主是主力的
主力的五日籌碼集中度
就是這五天裡面呢
主力到底是買超也賣超
平均來說
那10天呢是
這個真的講太多
沒有啦!各位我們現在還在講一個基本的東西啦
那個比較
比較那個
比較關鍵的我們留在影音課裡面講
好不好
比較關鍵的留在影音課裡面講
我們現在講一個基本的東西
至少把基本的東西教一下
各位不要這樣
你看
真的講太多了
都是付費內容
真的很薄
今天真的賺翻了
好啦 再回來
有沒有看到 主屋主持
我們有主力的重版金融度
力望也很漂亮
力望我有賺到啊
力望賺的可多了
我找一下我力望的那個
力望我是
上禮拜
上禮拜四
我們在火鍋店
我對面坐了阿忌
阿忌坐在我對面我跟他說
趕快買立望 我只差不能拿麥克風起來說
卡丁杯立望欸
因為不能啦 因為我不能對那個不認識的特定人
也不能講不認識 因為大部分都學員
我們至少不能對一些特定人
不過我們沒有收費 所以其實也還好
但是那時候我就跟阿忌說
趕快買立望 快點
立望這個點很甜
來來來 給各位看
來你看一下立望甜不甜
喔 力望在這裡非常非常甜
喔 超級無敵甜
來來 我來看一下 我來看一下
因為我前幾天我有發一個圖片
這是我的力望
喔 力望一直在 來這邊
來這裡
這裡
力望自己用融資買啊 資買
資買
有沒有
成交價格4090
這應該是主要賣的
我是買在這一天啊
我買在那個
你看一下一張賺
大概26萬
一張賺26萬多少錢
260塊
所以呢我買在這個位置
我買在這裡
大概3800左右
因為260塊
然後這個隔天
38多
所以這個點
就我在這附近跟阿姬亞說的
阿姬今天我們上有沒有上直播啊
我就跟他講
那我們有一學員這邊
有一學員那個住在附近也有聽到
阿姬美 這邊很甜啊
超甜 而且他有小力旺
我的宣傳就說 哥我沒有錢
你沒錢 小力旺啊 各位
小力旺沒有多少錢 各位
來吧 給各位看一下小力旺
啊 力旺是有小力旺 我說沒錢小力旺嘛
有個賣寶石姐的 他跟我說
力旺那麼貴 他沒錢
那麼貴 買小力旺好不好
小力旺多少錢 保證金
13萬 呦 那要那麼貴
保證金13萬應該有吧
因為他一張 這很貴啦 一張
這個天天應該只有11萬多啦
因為一張要400多萬嘛
一張400多萬但是你用小力旺的話才13萬
那13萬這兩天齁
光這兩天漲多少
各位看3800到4400
這兩天漲600塊
啊600塊多少錢齁
跟各位講一下
小力旺呢他是那個
100股的意思
所以呢600塊呢就賺6萬
賺6萬
你假如當時候買11萬多
那時候保證金應該是11萬多啦
你買11萬多齁
那11萬多
然後呢
漲600塊
就是賺6萬
這賺6萬
這有小型的啊
小型的
這個有
所以這個
這個點齁
那這個
立望呢
他就是我們的浪子回頭啦
就跟各位講
他那個形態啊各位呢 你看一下形態這形態態就浪子回頭我在這邊給各位看啊來來來在這邊給各位看
來看一下我的這個
這邊浪子回頭
經濟處之後跌20%
你看一下他的型態
他型態長這樣
型態長這樣有沒有
處之後跌20%嘛
買了130幾塊到現在160幾
我還沒有賣完
那時候買300多張
我陸續撿碼中了
還沒有賣完
剩下的就明天
明天留著吧
搞不好明天拉漲天
也不知道
反正136張
各位你算一下300
136塊370張
一張賺
3萬的話
一張賺3萬嘛
對到現在大概一張賺3萬
這370張就多少
大概可以賺1000萬
當然沒有留這麼多啦
沒留這麼多
好 這是經濟喔
經濟是這樣子喔
好 來看第二個看環宇
那環宇呢在這裡齁
4月27號處之後跌10%
4月27號 環宇在這個點
來 4991環宇 在這點
通知你
在這邊通知你齁 4月27號
通知你處之後跌10%
是不是通知你啊
通知你啊 那各位你看一下他的籌碼
我們還是一樣在看主力馬來超這條線
他往下跌 阻力买一槽油 治療金有跌嗎
沒有跌嘛 他跌不是因為阻力出貨啊
是因為沒人接啊 在跟各位講
他跌是因為 不是阻力出貨 是沒人接
有人賣一下 股價就跌下來嘛
對不對 因為沒有人接嘛
因為他這個被關20分了
被關20分 大家要入金太麻煩了 沒有人接
對不對 啊沒人接呢 沒人接怎麼辦
每天接呢這個
我去接啊好不好 我去接
這個我去接 我把它敲開的
來來來 這裡
4月27號這裡 各位看一下
還跌停欸 對不對
那我敲開的喔
各位 這邊是5375張我不會敲
538我敲的喔
我是負責敲開的
5張我不陪他啦
5張我不陪他玩
因為搞不好他都是5張啊
打瓊喔
打瓊又打瓊
打瓊
打瓊打瓊打瓊我就敲了下一筆有大單我就敲了我就敲了一敲538來來來來給各位看538
敲90張
那給各位看
現在是多少
這個4991 535
抱歉在就賺飯了
抱歉在
欸 懷疑喔
538一張是20萬喔
20萬
我沒有撐到現在啦
我撐到現在就發了
吃到現在多少
1800萬
沒吃到現在 沒有 沒有吃到現在
好不好 沒有沒有吃到現在
這是環語喔
好 來講訊心齁
那訊心呢就更好玩了
訊心更好玩了
來 訊心呢是在這裡
訊心在這邊
我們現在來看一下訊心的訊息
訊息的訊息啊
訊星 儲滯後跌20% 4月24號
4月24號這個點可以買嗎
來給各位看喔
這點可以買嗎
4月24號他的點在這裡
這邊 哥買嗎
當然不能買 為什麼
因為他還鎖住嘛 所以不要買
那我就研究一下籌碼
訊星我就研究一下籌碼
我發現 欸
他在這一天
賣的人齁 很特別齁
賣的人呢 我們叫他停損歌
但是那個 我們就不要講停損歌是誰了 好不好
就不要講停損歌是誰了
反正就賣的人叫停損歌
那當天呢 我就特別在PPR
特別在PPR 我特別講
各位呢 你去聽那個禮拜
就上禮拜天的PPR 我特別講說
訊心啊
就禮拜天的PPR
就是 來來來
就這一天的PPR 我特別有講
這一天
這個
呃這裡
各位PPE你去看這一天的
4月20號這篇
你去看這一篇
那這一篇呢我就講
訊息有停損歌啊
停損歌是拿來發紅包的
我再跟各位講一次喔
股票都這樣
只要有誰停損
而且是月大咖
月大咖的停損
那我們就說 訊心哥有停損哥的紅包
就停損哥會把它賣下來停損哥會賣下來賣下來那個點子超甜的因為只要停損哥一不賣他就準備會長這一定這樣子嘛他不賣最大賣壓都沒了嘛
大家買了就
都沒了嘛
所以呢那天我去做什麼事喔
再跟各位講
那天我去做
我做什麼事
我幫停損哥解脫了
好不好
那天我幫停損哥解脫
來來來
來 各位啊
這個
欸 各位你可以用
但是我還是不要點
你有興趣的你自己用你的
用你的那個
你用你的那個什麼
用你的
籌碼可以借你自己點
這個
訊息呢來來這邊
這我買的給你看沒關係
這我買的這不是我買的
這也不是我買的這也不是我買的
雖然同一個分點但他不是我賣的
但這個點我買的
這點我買的81張
來來來給各位看
分點告訴你都沒關係
81張
信心在那邊84張
我這裡面還有其他的
但不是全部都他
還有其他價位的
但是81張買了36
這個點我買
買的
好不好
買了
這沒有賣
那訊心呢到現在是多少
到現在多少
84張363嘛
那各位你看一下訊心現在多少錢
521有沒有看到
363 521
欸這多少啊
一張160塊
訊心我今天
最後的最後
我賣在今天的開盤
今天開盤
祝他幸福啦
後面沒有我的事啦
最後最後我賣在今天開盤
這裡
這邊9張 我今天賣9張 我看一下
這邊應該看得到吧
賣9張喔 最後的最後
賣9張
可能有別人的在裡面
但是我的
我那個賣9張 我看一下有沒有
我現在還沒看他的那個對照
這邊 哇
哇 今天有人賣20張
這分點不只我啦 不只我一個
不只我一個
小哥畫面可以切掉
什麼東西啊
泡講太多
好啦時間快到了
他不講我講
好啦就這樣子啦齁
來來來最後最後我賣賣一隻
就是我有買這個
362啦
那有些賣521啦
所以我一張
一張呢有的賺到160塊
160塊 很肥喔
好不好
160塊喔
好啦 就這樣子
他也是一樣啊
你看一下這型態
好不好
好
所以呢
重點呢你要有什麼東西
重點呢你要有個好軟體
第一個 他會通知你
通知通知通知嗎
他會通知你
啊第二個呢
我們現在齁 我們再把它優化
那不只他啦 我們還有像
剛剛跟各位講的力望啦
來來 剛剛跟各位講的力望
這裡
來 這邊 剛剛跟各位講的力望
力望 我有買 我有買
我也賣掉一些了
那有的今天賣
那跟各位講
你不一定要買股票
你也可以買期貨
像力旺他有小力旺
所以小力旺我也有玩
他有大力旺期貨
也有小力旺期貨
來來
再給各位看
3.59來這邊
怎麼樣
他有期貨啊
有期貨可以玩
小力旺有期貨可以玩
他的錢沒有很多
13萬而已
一般來講13萬大部分人都有啦
13萬
然後在這一波上也賺了6萬
也賺很...也...
也算賺很大
那是因為
他被關20分鐘他的槓桿變小
不然平常他的保證金沒有這麼貴
平常保證金沒有這麼貴
好 那這個
呃 這個 這個呢 你必須要有一個好的軟體
好的軟體呢 就會通知你
來 我們來看一下
好的軟體會通知你
來 再給各位看這個處置成績喔
我們來看一下4月27號
4月27號那天我買最多 那天我買一陀拉鍋
來 你自己看一下4月27號
這是當天的訊號
4月27號當天的訊號很多
但是幾乎是檔檔標
你自己回過頭看
來來來
我現在把這27號的訊號給你看
當天有很多
那有很多我們不可能沒當買
那我就會去看什麼
我去看籌碼比較好的
籌碼比較好的
會看籌碼比較好的這個股票在哪裡
所以各位呢你看到訊號呢你記得去看籌碼比較好來 各位 你看到這裡齁你可以直接開個籌碼可以 來來來吧
我這邊直接開籌碼可以我們來對照一下啦 好不好
這個檔檔標
4月27號
來啊 各位看一下
827雨簪
4月27號 我們把它直接弄到4月27號這天給各位看
4月27號 827在這邊出現訊號
這裡啊 4月27號嘛
齁 來
然後呢 642 這很多啊 64231爾的
在這裡出現訊號 當然跌停 跌停我們建議都是隔天買
各位 跌停都建議隔天買 你看隔天買多漂亮
4971浪子回 497ID
來我現在對照 左邊出現的 我直接打那個
打給各位看 497在這邊 浪子回頭
然後1785多萬再起了
就沒有
我們是
那個
我們做什麼事啊
我們是讓紫回頭找買點
東山再起找賣點
再跟各位講一次喔
讓紫回頭找賣點
東山再起找賣點
來 三黃也是啊
三黃這邊我就注意了
但是這個位置我沒有買很多
因為他到這裡我覺得沒有跌很多
我到這邊才買
三黃我買在24塊
24塊附近喔
哇24.124 因為他在這邊我覺得位置還不夠低
所以我沒有說他一出去我馬上買
沒有
來 永光 浪子回頭
有沒有 4月27號 浪子回頭
這點浪子回頭很漂亮
反正這邊出現了你就可以自己去找
我泰谷 泰谷儲智後跌28
泰谷儲智後跌28 你看一下 4月27號在這裡
跌停當然不會買 但隔天就要買
所以泰國隔天我有買一個開盤獎
有沒有
泰國有買一個開盤獎
一對不讓我講
講太多我剛剛講你
你用了處置神器你就怎麼樣
你就這樣
小哥落屁屁的時間快到了
不要再講了
有買神就叫小哥閉嘴
真的
好啦不要講
不要講 我們那個
其實裡面還有一個
我覺得未來因應崩盤的時候
因為現在的盤其實是蠻恐怖的我覺得有點怎麼樣這個實在漲太多了現在盤這個蠻恐怖的 我覺得有點有點怎麼樣 這個實在長太多了啊 現在盤這個這個太恐怖了 但是這麼恐怖
你也不能怎麼樣
這麼恐怖的時候 你不能說不參與啊
欸 小哥真的盤很恐怖
我不參與 可以嗎
不行 你還是要參與
為什麼現在很恐怖
我們來看五兆男的聽牌
五兆餒
欸 聯發科是台股市值第三名
再跟各位講
第三名喔 第三名
聯發科四次突破五兆第三名 他比鴻海還大
你想想看鴻海處置
你是什麼感覺
鴻海處置不算什麼 為什麼因為聯發科比他大 聯發科五兆了
鴻海 鴻海不到五兆
鴻海不知道幾兆 三四兆 反正聯發科五兆
五兆都聽牌
所以呢
對這波行情多了幾分敬畏 你很敬畏喔 你會覺得這波行情這很強
那很強 你不能在外面講說
哇這行情很強 那個很恐怖 大家要小心啊
不要再做多了 每天那個
每天要講一些很恐怖的那個
那個要崩盤的
崩盤的話 絕對不能這樣子 你要積極參與
再跟各位講 雖然這麼恐怖 我還是積極參與
但是我都會避險
我都會避險喔 在跟各位講 我都會避險
會找一些東西去避險
所以呢 這次很恐怖的 所以
呃 避險怎麼避喔
避險怎麼避呢
我們呢有一個很厲害的東西啊
叫做雙刀戰法
喔 雙刀戰法
來 各位
我今天呢有佈局一些這檔股票啦
我已經有買一些了喔
欸 這一檔
我有買一些了
給各位看啦 沒關係
我買一點啦
買一些
但是呢 我要避險
我要避險呢 我就要找雙刀戰法
從雙刀戰法裡面 找避險的標的
從雙刀戰法裡面找避險的標的
那這個要怎麼找呢
好 這個呢 我們要
保留一些 好不好
保留一些喔 我們要保留一些給那個
給有買軟體的人
因為你要避險嘛 避險就是做空嘛
對不對 啊你總不能
你總不能做空要糟告天下嘛 對不對
做空不能糟告天下
做空不能昭告天下
呵呵呵
所以呢 我們避險的東西呢我們就留給那個留給懂軟體的人那這種避險 我跟各位講它在未來喔 其實我們用這個雙刀戰法
我們做了很多套利
也不能講套利啦
就做很多 反正就做很多雙刀啦
那這種講套利好像穩賺
它也沒有到穩賺 但是賺的機率喔
我們從目前為止到現在賺的機率90幾%
那雙刀就是一多一公
那基本上雙刀怎麼做喔
那個你有買軟體的
我們的影音在裡面
你都可以好好的去研究
好研究
好
好 來
那處置坐牢中呢
再跟各位講
處置坐牢中裡面呢
還有一個東西我覺得蠻重要的
就是我會看那個位階排序
位階排序
那位階排序裡面有個月限協率
月限協率負的什麼意思
它代表說
代表說怎麼樣
代表說它是弱勢股
它弱勢股我們是不碰的
來看一下
這個9949這是弱勢股
這我們不碰
有沒有看到這弱勢股
弱勢股的處置不玩的
不玩
我們不玩弱勢股的人
像這種這種月線往下我們不玩
不玩這一種
我要玩強勢股
所以月線協定最好是大於1
那今天的建設就很漂亮
有沒有
今天建設的這個很漂亮
但他今天阻力醜了點 因為今天
今天有人在砍
今天有人在砍 把他砍醜了
不然平常他真的很漂亮
今天有兆風啊
停損仔
欸欸
他是算停利仔
他有點停損
好啦停損仔
停損仔
來
各位看到停損仔了喔
停損仔
停損哥 不能叫人家仔
停損哥
停損哥的累計買賣超呢
來看一下 他還有六十幾趟
當然是不全然是他啦
但是我覺得他應該今天就可以賣完了
因為今天建策沒有跌停
今天建策沒有跌停
所以我跟各位講他沒有跌停嘛
所以今天趙鋒他應該是可以把他的庫存賣完
他有跌停就是賣不完那我們可能就隔天接
但是呢他的庫存這個趙鋒停損哥
可能來發紅包的我不曉得
我不曉得他要發紅包 發白包了 我不知道
我不知道他要發什麼包
但是呢 他到這位置呢 我就會接一點
到這位置 我會接一點 好不好
會接點這個
這個這個股價
來
那為什麼到這位置接點
來給各位看這裡
這邊
各位看這裡
他是
月限協率大於1裡面
處置股很多
這裡有很多
但是呢
他是所有裡面
這跟各位講
他所有裡面
月限協率大於1裡面
位階最低的
處置股好像有六十幾檔嘛
他是位階最低的喔
所以我覺得建設這個位置其實還不錯
我覺得還不錯啊 但他有點貴啊
有點貴呢 各位沒關係
這個我今天就應用了有點貴
有點貴呢 我就用小建設 有沒有
各位小建設看到沒有
小建設14萬
我用小建設 哇
今天這個還有人砍跌停啊
小建設
小建策
這裡
所以各位呢你就可以來
來找一下
找這種
再給各位看
這個處置股呢我們要找月線協率大有一
那什麼叫月線協率呢
來這邊給各位看
這裡
這個月線呢
這邊是上面有個值
因為協率大有一的意思是說
他每天月線往上1%
你看昨天是4675嘛 今天是4728
4675到4728
這大概是多了多少 多了50幾
所以呢他的月線每天多1%
他每天多 他是每天多1.1%
那這種每天多1.1% 我跟各位講
通常他的回檔都是第一次回檔
就從高檔的第一次回檔
他預見才會這麼抖
那高檔後的第一次回檔呢
大部分都蠻強的
再講一次喔
高檔後第一次回檔都蠻強的
那第二次回檔就不一定那麼強
所以呢有一檔股票你趕快小心一點
這檔股票
他最近位階也蠻低的
來這一檔
這叫光盛
光盛位階-2
但是他月限協率是0.1
代表說他的月限走平了
來這邊
光盛的月線走平的
那這種走平的月線到月線不是好買點他的好買點會在下通道走坪的月線下通道是好買點
然後很陡的月線
來我們
再看一下3042
很陡的月線
到了月線附近都是好買點
3042這也是好買點嘛
對不對
你看我們剛剛給各位看的那幾檔
3042啊
經濟啊 環宇啊
對不對
6451啊 迅清啊
靠近月線都是好買一點
但這天跌停不會買 我們一定等隔天買
再跟各位講 跌停
不會買
跌停不會買
跌停等隔天 因為跌停有可能會跌嘛
一直講付費怎麼
不會啦 我跟你講 我們那個最重要的後面的雙刀
雙刀的付費會知道啦
雙方會也知道 反正
剩下你就要有軟體
才知道 好不好
那反正這
這些lowhow我們會把那個通知喔 我們就放在那個
這邊
這邊會有通知
哇這是今天的通知 哇 力望處置回漲後漲10%
出現了
所以力望我今天在賣
喔 我今天有在賣力望
撒冷房我還沒賣 為什麼 因為他漲停嘛
欸 再講一次
跌停你不要買
漲停你不要賣
像今天上網漲停我當然不會賣啊
我等隔天賣嘛
你懂嗎
隔天再賣
好 浪子維手今天有出現大量喔
但大量今天逼近跌停
但也沒有鎖死啊
所以明天大量再跌我要買
明天大量再跌
這個籌碼是籌的
但明天他再跌呢
欸又是我是覺得又是一個不錯的買點
但是我會
我會
我會分批接啦
這個我會分批接
我可以提早跟你講
是這樣
那我就按照這個處置來做
然後呢4月份呢
各位你看這幾筆你就知道
這幾筆就
它買點就很漂亮了嘛
所以4月份
我就抓一個月
來來來這邊
我抓一個月這裡
4月5號到5月5號
抓一個月這個戶頭賺了3300
還有一些我還沒賣
所以呢實際上賣完是賺更多
裡面還有一些可轉載的虧損
可轉載這個4月份有一些虧損在裡面
所以實際上的獲利 現股的獲利是更多這戶頭是專門買可轉載的那就後面我就也完全處置了這樣子
好
所以這個很好玩啊
所以呢 我們要做什麼事呢
來
做什麼事 我這邊已經寫了啦
浪子回頭你不賠 東山再騎你是誰啊
有沒有
浪子回頭你不賠
喔 東山再起你是誰
看到沒有
喔 所以呢 意思怎麼樣 讓子回頭找機會賠嘛
喔 所以呢 我們的那個
欸 我們的
這個其實很簡單
這軟體怎麼用呢
讓子回頭好好賠啊
喔 好不好
所以這軟體呢 我們就把它
溶縮成這幾個字
好不好 來來來
賺錢的我都寫出來了啦
好不好 我都寫出來
你要做的事情呢 就這樣子而已啦
你要做的就是這樣
我再把它寫大一點
好像可以到99
對
沒了 就這樣而已 很簡單
浪子回頭好好賠啊
東山再起柴香水啊
好不好
浪子回頭好好賠
東山再起才香水
就這樣
所以就是浪子回頭呢 你看一下籌碼
在這你要看一下籌碼齁
那我們現在呢 現在有直接把數字寫在旁邊了
所以呢 儲置股齁
來這邊 儲置做好鐘
右邊呢 他有一些數字
這邊呢 是儲置 主主石
主主持喔 這個數字假如好的話
其實拉回都是好買點
這跟各位講 這種數字好了 拉回都好買點
那土字可以用全證買嗎 可以 我們很多學員都用全證買
我建議有現股買現股 有期貨也可以買期貨
但正價差 通常都正價差啦 所以正價差不要太多可以買
那你也可以用全證 但全證要好好找
好不好 全證怎麼找呢 去看上一集
上一集有教各位
有教各位覺得怎麼找
好 那這邊有一個累積漲模
累積漲模是說
他被關了之後呢他跌多少被關了之後跌多少你看一下 最近被關跌比較多的是西華西華之前蠻漂亮的 我覺得不錯 泰谷
泰谷也不錯 但泰谷已經漲上來了
他之前有跌更慘
這是
處置做好中的累積漲跌幅
所以累積漲跌幅 跌越多的 假如籌碼不錯的
欸 像泰谷啊 泰谷籌碼不錯
來看一下
但他已經上來了 泰谷我在低點 我買
這個點最漂亮
你看泰股連續跌
連續跌停是讓你找買點
對不對
連續跌停
讓你找買點
連續跌停找買點
所以這個
泰股這個點是蠻不錯的
所以呢
你可以從累積跌幅去找股票
從未接排序找股票
找什麼股
找浪子回頭股
浪子回頭股
那你說啊這裡都不行那沒關係啊
靠通知通知你
通知
通知你的手機會響
通知響了
響了你就看一下浪子回頭什麼股票
今天的大量
還有誒
陳籃
反正就這樣
這是今天的通知啦
8小時9小時4小時
這是今天的通知
反正就是靠浪子回頭
找買點
好不好
這個
再給各位講
浪子回頭好好賠
東山再起財香水啦
就是你從浪子回頭裡面
找到你要買的股票
好不好
可以買全證
買現股 買期貨 買零股
都可以
很多高價股 很多學員都是買零股
買零股也OK
那儲置這樣子喔
儲置有分 5分跟20分
5分的呢
聯花科5分 那不用怕啦
那個沒筆9張內
一天29張
那20分比較麻煩
要入金
所以20分鐘呢 你可以用期貨來買
可以用期貨來買
那20分鐘股票通常都會有正價差
所以期貨可能貴一點
到時候你可能要考慮一下
那你也可以用全證買
但通常全證造勢都不太好
所以呢 全證你要好好挑
全證切記啊
切記你的那個
你的銀行波動率不要買太高
銀行波動率買太高呢 就比較恐怖
好啦
來 這個
來
來看一下 先看學員的回答
學員的留言啊
感謝喬哥處理神器真的太好用 配合雙刀跟浪子回頭
持陸續的穩定獲利
再次感謝小哥各種無私操作的分享
這是分享好不好
分享 分享賺錢的方法
好不好
我們分享賺錢的方法給各位
我們買點買那麼漂亮
跟很多人講我們的買點只會變醜
再跟各位講
你把這些招式學獲了之後
我的買點只會變得更醜而已
不會變得比較漂亮
所以我們是分享
這個獲利的方法
你要當酸民 趕快走 趕快走 趕快離開
不要來看我的直播啦 因為我不想分享給你
好
主治股真的是賞物很好獲利的機會
每週的小哥直播跟小哥讓你成長就做必看的節目
小哥總是無視的分享主力籌碼還有獲利方法
相關的軟體更讓賞物更輕鬆的提升勝率
上此體課也學著盆滿撥滿
總之多關注小哥必然讓你受益多多
知道都知道 信小哥得招票
知道就知道
好
每次聽小哥拆解籌碼
真的有種原來是這樣的感覺
以前看板總是物理看花
聽完分析才發現原來這些數據
背後查得大物的意圖
小哥把複雜的籌碼講得千言一懂
那我這種小短護也敢容嘴的把
每次下課心裡踏成都感覺功力又深厚一點
好 恭喜這三個得到軟體
得到軟體
然後我們再看那個學員
這處置
那個小秘書有幫我
幫我截圖一下
我看一下
我看一下小秘書結的圖在哪裡
這兩這邊
紮結的圖啊
感謝小哥 哇這獲利
這個是財勝科
經濟喔經濟賣的
謝謝小哥幫我加賽 跟其他大成部位不能比
下次上完股期再用期貨下下看
感謝小哥其實團隊讓處置變好多
這是我們群組裡面喔 群組裡面
就是我們有兩個群
喔 處置有兩個群 喔 第一個群目前是500人
呃 來看一下
第一個群目前500人啊
這裡
500人
喔
這裡啊
來 你各位看 這裡
500人啊 沒有離開啦 沒有人離開
喔 500人沒有人離開
喔 沒有人離開 500人
所以這個500人裡面常常
大家都在裡面分享喔
盤中我也不太會在裡面講話啦因為盤中不大適合講所以你看到盤中在帶單不是我啦那我可能帶單盤中的不一樣要死的就帶單
防得要死
除非你盤中坐在我旁邊
你坐我旁邊就跟你講說我在買什麼
我會跟你講
所以我們那個吃火鍋的時候
吃火鍋的時候
有人來我旁邊
我就跟他講說我在買什麼
因為他在我旁邊嘛
就可以講
那我們那天
我那天火鍋店也一堆人去吃了
喔
來
謝謝小哥
這個讓褚子變好做
這是他這個另外學人賺的
哎呀這個賺的應該不是褚子啊
這華泰式之前的
來看
本月月節大賺一票
中央大賺完褚子成績無敵了
賺錢了
好
經濟賺錢了
褚子團體賣4萬5超便
買一套做一檔
可以抵三年
哇
這是經濟
然後這邊
哇
這賺40萬
趕小哥褚子
這邊賺經濟
其實大部分都賺到經濟 連貌我有賺到
連貌跟經濟我都有賺到
今天也入貸兩支儲置會當買 五月裡費用
欸很好
反正各位記者 台勝科這也是儲置股
經理科也是
連側也是 連側也是儲置股
連側這個應該是先空嘛
先空再多
來看這邊 和聲檔 密枉石都是儲置股
靠主子賺到回頭買等上檔 密枉石
哇這邊是
這邊應該是做到
欸他做到誰啊
哇他做到全新的當充啊
這是做到金居 金居儲置股
這金利科 儲置股
好 儲置股也可以用全鎮吧
你看一下這個學人就用全鎮做
目前秉持著小哥讓指揮說
東安在野訊這賺回儲置神秘的費用
能買幾套了
好 這個就是
欸 發明這個就是
讓大家來獲利的
最後呢我們工商一下
這邊
為什麼這禮拜有
因為上禮拜一堆跟我講說他沒買到
一直叫我們再開一次
所以我們直播快展限定
進階版PBIP手機又會在45000
第2年期續訂價16800
16800為什麼這是45000呢
因為我們有
進階段體一連擊全線
還有進階線上課程全攻略
我們在5月
5月20幾號有一堂那個課
實體課
你不能來實體課或線上課
那是專門開給牛買這套軟體的人來上的那我就在那堂課呢再跟各位講我最近的一些策略那這個現在課程裡面呢
還有一小時完成版
基礎處置策略 進階處置策略
雙刀戰法策略
每月實戰陪跑
每個月呢我們會
復盤策略更新到2026年底
還有專屬討論群組
這群組500個人
那另外一群300多人
目前沒人離開啦
喔 我要你回 大家都在裡面
大家都在裡面喔
好 這個喔
這個限時活動只到5月6號11點59
時間到就關閉方案就沒有了喔
喔 那下次再開就不知道什麼時候了
喔 上次開完一堆人說他
他沒買到
所以我們這次呢 再開一次
喔 這次再開一次
喔
好啦 所以這個有優惠就這樣啦
有優惠就這樣 沒買到優惠就有點可惜啦
好 所以這個儲置
真的很好用
這個跟各位分享了
獲利都在我的臉書都跟各位講了
那我非常希望聯發科
進儲置
他進儲置呢有
來給各位看這邊
我們有聽牌啦
喔
連發哥呢他有聽牌的
價格
這邊
喔所以連發哥呢他假如聽牌
其實我就覺得他聽牌
呃他真的
處置影響沒有很大
但是我是希望他可以怎麼樣
我是希望他可以回檔
喔
對
我希望他可以回檔啊因為連發哥的籌碼也很漂亮
喔他要處置回檔
要處置回檔 假如聯發哥浪子回頭
哇賽 那就美了
真的 聯發哥浪子回頭會很美
會很美齁 這個
大家明天也不用去追了啦
因為他已經跳空一支線了
而且今天越鎖的人越鎖越少
他盤中其實鎖張住的變少了齁
他這尾盤被補上去了
那今天盤中也有出點量
所以我覺得明天不要追
假如明天聯發哥有回頭的話
那是很完美的齁
喔那是很完美的喔
這個明天
呃明天不是有回頭
明天他要被關之後回頭啦
喔那我們當然是要出現到
出現了浪子回頭訓導喔假設連發科有浪子回頭訓導哇我一一定會好好買啊因為連發科他不只有連發科的期貨
他也有小連發科
嗯 跟各位講
最近這種
小連發科的個股期其實蠻多的啦
連發科
小連發科
哎呦 目前才43000
以後會變貴喔
未來會變貴 為什麼
因為
那個儲置股呢
他的
他的保證變貴
但是連發科這個
也不會貴太多啦
因為他5分鐘不會貴太多
20分鐘就超貴
他現在是4萬3而已
所以假設聯發哥有回檔
他的保證金可能就在4萬塊附近
那就小聯發哥可以買
因為聯發哥這位置我也買不下去了啦
3000...3200你現在追
他萬一處置的回檔
那一回檔你可能又很心痛
有的分點搞不好又要停損
那我們要找的是
這些分點在處置期間
停損哥
假如有停損哥
這個回來的話
喔 假如有停損哥
讓股價回來的話
聯發科會出現一個很好的買點喔
再跟各位講
聯發科現在這樣子呢
就很像那個當年的經濟
經濟呢 我在這裡跟各位講
各位 記不記得
記不記得 我在這邊跟你講說
經濟呢 我們希望他處置 希望他好好的被關
最好是回黨 經濟回黨會買爆他
再跟各位講
經濟我說 最好回黨會買爆他
我已經買了300張
加齊柚當然不只啦
買了300張
300張 各位你看 300張 130幾
130幾到現在160幾
也是可以賺1000萬啦
賺1000萬
所以呢 這個
利用處置回黨
利用處置回檔
好好的買
聯發科
跟很想聯發科的
處置回檔
所以我們非常希望聯發科明天被關
非常希望他被關
那非常希望他被關之後
他回檔讓我買
但是我沒有叫你放空
你不要隨便讓空
空股票是很恐怖的
但是我是希望他回檔
我希望他再回檔但是我不是叫你空
我要上車啊
我要上車
那這處置神機呢
我們在3月份
第一批賣的喔
呃...很多人
第一批賣的都把
賺回來了
很多啦
我們在
你可以看到心得嗎
你看他
你看群組500個人
沒有半個人退你就知道了
第一波賣的大概就是
那個第一群
500個人
都沒有人退
大家運用我們的方法
在三四月園賺的盆滿波滿
那你現在要不要買隨便你
你不買也別怪機
要不要買隨便你
我們這個
這個軟體呢
這個
發
欸應該說 發明這個好軟體
就是讓相信我的人
相信我的人 這個來獲利的
那3月份相信的已經獲利
上次買相信的也獲利
那我相信這次買的之後也會獲利
好 那這就是今天的
這個處置神器了
處置神器了 唉呦 10點4分了
一個人叫我不要再講了
哈哈
那處置神器的web版呢
我們會在五月中旬問世
VVIP全演可以搶先體驗
搶先體驗
組織神器的Web版
好啦
來來來來看一下學員的留言
這邊有沒有看到
真的早轉回來謝謝小哥
轉回來不要再說了
轉回來 轉翻了
時間你才會開去錄音
這都是那個
欸
我們都沒有
都沒有找人在裡面留言
沒有
好不好
好
錄PV了
傻傻賣
賺回來錄PV
就這樣
Web版另外再買
不用
不用另外再買
好啦
好
那我們今天的這個直播呢
就講到這邊
這很好用啦
直播講到這裡
那處置神器呢
可以幫助你怎麼
我們每天會有處置日報
那我會有這個統計
那統計它會變動
變動了你就可以
你就可以做為最近的一些策略
它的變動呢你可以做為最近的策略
因為它會跟盤勢有關
那最近的數值代表說
這盤勢太好了
所以你就可以做了一些策略
最近的數值代表說這盤是太好了
所以20分鐘出關呢都蠻強的都蠻強的所以呢你20分鐘出關了你就要考慮你該怎麼做好那這組織神器啦
那最後呢
最後這邊
最後工商一下我還有
呃哇這個5月13號有
高配級籌碼全攻略
那他會這個春季講座
這跟Smart合作的啦
這個Smart合作這堂課呢我們會講一下
最近的籌碼還有一些
還有今年的一些除血型的工業
回來這堂課跟各位講
好
那股票期貨實戰班呢
是5月15號
5月17號還有5月23號
台中高雄台北廠
副業直播呢是台北廠
那5月24號呢有處置課
那5月24號這堂課呢
我們目前就只有開放給
那個有買處置神器的人來聽
好
那小賣籌碼K的在這裡
我們會送大物分點清單
然後呢 最後喜歡今天直播的歡迎按讚訂閱
留言關心的喔 抽景品娃娃或軟體
那最後呢 我們來抽獎一下
股票期貨實戰班台中場市幾號上課
幾號上課
儲置成績沒有儲置的會有用嗎
呃 我有去研究一下
2022年的盤比較弱
但2022年的儲置股還是蠻
還是有啦 但不能講蠻多啦
就明顯的 當然一定比2026年來的少
所以
你要趁現在啊 各位
你要好好把握當下
現在這麼瘋狂的盤
現在這麼瘋狂的盤 而且這麼震盪的盤
處置是非常好做的時候啦
假如不好做 我不會跟你講
就是好做才跟你講說 你要趁現在好好做
我遇到認識的時候 我跟他講說 你現在好好做處置
因為處置有跟好做跟不好做的事情
現在是很好做的事情
現在是超好做的事情
你要撐下來好好做
撐下來好好做
那你假如很害怕盤勢的震盪
你可以做那個雙刀戰法
那雙刀戰法可以幫你路過盤勢的震盪
那雙刀戰法呢
那個比較難
那個也比較進階
那個呢你買儲置神器呢
我們在儲置的這個
裡面會有儲置影音
就把雙刀戰法講得很清楚
那我也會偶爾呢
會在那個群組分享說
你可以來觀察一下像我就我週末的時候有跟學員講你可以觀察一下全新全新從明天開始全新跟摩檔股票
它的雙刀戰法的
它的比值
那檔股票我就不要講是誰了
這個全新跟摩檔股票的比值
我覺得應該會有點變化
那像建設
我待會跟各位講
建設有一檔
待會我傳到群組去
各位呢你可以觀察一下
建設跟摩檔股票的比值
在下禮拜呢會產生變化
不是下禮拜
在未來會產生變化
建設跟摩檔股票
讓股票呢我就不要在這裡講出來了
待會呢我就傳到那兩個群組去
建設跟摩檔股票的比值
那個是我目前為止我覺得
那個比較適合做雙刀
但是各位你看看就好
你不用跟著做
那我是會做的人
反正我講的東西我都會做
但是你不用跟著做
那我不希望太多人狙擊我
所以呢我只好跟這兩群講就好了
建設跟那個跟摩擋股票
那建設當然是做多啦
但是建設做多
你要狙擊我
那我也不知道怎麼講啦
你要怎麼狙擊我呢我不知道
好 來 線上亂數產生器
來來來來
欸?
AI翻譯員
什麼鬼 AI翻譯員
怎麼AI翻譯員來
來啊我最近都來研究AI啊
這邊AI翻譯員來跟我打廣告
呵呵呵呵
中獎5四
喔5跟4
好啦
那這個
這個這個
我們剛剛講建設齁
我現在就給傳一下
所以各位
你家群組有一個好處啦
就是我們看到什麼呢
我會跟各位分享
看到什麼會跟各位分享
這個因為建策呢 它的位階我是覺得蠻甜的
它的位階我覺得蠻甜的
所以呢我就跟學員分享
那建策呢 它可以跟
它可以跟某一檔來
來好好研究一下
好 這一檔
好 來吧
我把張圖啊
我把張圖傳給我的處置群
好我現在傳了已經傳好了
各位現在數字群你可以看得到我現在傳的雙刀那雙刀呢就是一多一空啦一多一空那我會給各位看那個欸這個雙刀他的
他的這個
分享的
雙刀的狀況
雙刀你要怎麼研究
那通常因為雙刀我研究很透徹啦
所以呢我大概可以看得出來
欸雙刀
在什麼情況下下手的勝率比較高
好啦
我已經傳給大家兩群了
有加入的就看到
好 那我們今天的直播呢
就講到這裡啦
這個歡迎各位加入我們
處置的獲利行列
獲利行列 那這個
看到浪子回頭
你就再看一下籌碼
籌碼不錯的
好好賠啊 好好賠啊
東山再起才香水啊
東山再起代表說他至少漲10%
我再講一次喔
東山再起至少漲10%
東山再起的股票太多了
來來我們看一下
來東山再起的處置
東山再起
來來多安在這裡
多安在你太多了
所以你看一下東山再起東山再起
東山再起東山再起東山再起東山再起
太多東山再起
這東山再起都是他有出現
浪子回頭訊號
浪子回頭
東山再起 你看到浪子回頭
再看到東山再起 他就10%了
不是說你10%就要賣光 沒有
我的迅金賣了
賺了快30%
迅金30%嘛 賺賺
對 迅金30%嘛 還到啊 看一下
6451 各位看一下這幾%
你看這邊
362到521
160塊
快30%了嘛 對不對 還沒到30%了
喔
呵呵呵呵
好啦好啦
那一對人趕我走
一對人不要我再講
好啦我就讓紙回頭好買就對了啦
就這樣子那麼簡單好不好
就這麼簡單的東西
那做當衝做的不好的
就是玩處之腳不要玩當衝好不好
當衝真的比較難
當衝真的比較難因為當衝很吃心態的
很吃心態的齁
尤其是錢越少
心態越崩
心態越崩所以錢少不要玩當衝
你要玩處置喔 那處置呢你可以
你可以買權證嘛 可以買古其嘛 古其他的
他的量都他的
他的保證金不用很多喔 好
好啦以上
跟各位分享喔 我要
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:10:00 起〕